Found my mark.
In two, one, action.
AL BERMAN: My name
is Al Berman, I'm
the executive producer and
showrunner of Yellowstone Live.
JEFF HOGAN: Name is Jeff Hogan.
I'm going to be filming
beavers, possibly some cougars.
AL BERMAN: Nobody's
really had the vision
to take on something this big.
National Geographic
is the first.
JEFF HOGAN: My passion for the
wildlife came before my passion
for filmmaking.
When I'm in the
wilds, I'm at home.
AL BERMAN: This is how
the wildlife really is
in Yellowstone, in real time.
It's kind of like the
ultimate reality documentary.
Here we go.
AL BERMAN: Yellowstone
it is one of the biggest
volcanoes in the world.
I wouldn't be surprised
if we're all surprised.
JEFF HOGAN: This is real.
This is live.
Anything can happen.
That's the magic in Yellowstone.
I think that's good.
AL BERMAN: Cool.
That was great guys.